[Music]
self kidnapping news submitted by phone
at ho a teen staged her own kidnapping
which triggered an Amber Alert and a
citywide manhunt Green Hyun died it was
like these [ __ ] Amber Alerts already
like I'm on the lookout for a green head
when I see this I'm like I can't wait to
[ __ ] jump through someone's eyes
three of them last week it's almost as
if there hasn't been one in a while and
it's almost as if like somebody
complained and they turned him off and
then they were like come on we gotta
help and then they turned him back on so
now we're all like how the [ __ ] you turn
that off you know my first thought is
like oh oh my god this poor kid I'm
always like where's the preferences for
yeah yeah so this girl a 16 year old
girl she's from New York and that's
where this happened I highly doubt it
was the same time cuz she wanted her
boyfriend look for her
no so alright so initially I will just
show you the surveillance footage we
went out and it's a really bad quality
footage but what you're gonna see is the
16 meters keepers on - all right the 16
year old girl is walking down the street
with her mother when this car pulls up
and three guys come out and they like 15
year-old girl into the car and the mom's
probably did it because to do all of
that
she's just that rebellious age and her
mom she probably hates her oh you why
she did it to a sleepover this is worse
than my 1990s TV show oh oh [ __ ] she's
fighting them yes this is just as
traumatizing that would wouldn't it be
nice if you had a gun at that moment you
just spray inside the car
this girl didn't know that her mom
actually has a has a carry permit yeah
she just pulls it out just blasts all
three my blood yeah so [ __ ] shoot out
the tires after I kill them these dead
people are going anywhere for sure
they're not so it turns out ok so then
that happened
and then the mom went to the cops they
did this whole Amber Alert it was a
citywide manhunt oh and then a few hours
later that's when this girl resurfaced
and she walked up to these cops cuz she
popped up in the same spot where she was
taken she walked up to these cops and
then let them know that that was her
because at that same time - the cops
were looking at like the the missing
poster and they were like man I hope
she's ok so then that's when she went to
police station and she let like
eventually came clean about the fact
that she staged it all and it was so she
can be with her 23 year old Crips gang
banger once arrested for murder
boyfriend and this was because the mom
wanted like she was talking about we
like uprooting the family and going back
to Honduras and that's when the girl did
worse over here than his back home it's
like a modern Romeo and Juliet yeah and
hey and his name is Takashi six right
yeah so then that's the reason why she
did it she gave more attention now to
her gang member
boyfriend yeah what at 16 you know oh no
and you know she thinks she thinks
that's the love of her life she thinks
one Direction's good music yeah this is
going through a lot of things this is
this is but this lends itself to being
like what's going on I'm not to blame
the mom but something's going on in that
house yeah you know I mean something's
going on or nothing she's terribly
traumatizing to that mom I'm sure she
like you don't you know
who's the girl wondrous yeah now she's
going to Honduras per [ __ ] sugar have
you ever seen someone who looks more
like they're going to Honduras after
this in your life TV how do you say it
again Honduras Honduras Honduras they're
always in lon Norris yes
Honduras isn't it on dudas yes own do -
let's see some blue and white flag if I
do that I sound like I'm ordering at a
Mexican restaurant go huh can I get some
Honduras no no on Randy you wanna be my
stepdad
yeah stepdad always tries to speak
Spanish at a Mexican restaurant and
people hate it yeah I'm saying no
because he goes like a Guapo by the way
he says it and they go you want some
water you know see nothing why don't
bother
non-spanish speakers put this weird
accent on it when it sounds like they're
making fun of Spanish so that even
though they're trying to speak Spanish
it just sounds like they're making fun
of Jay can't win basically I think what
I think I think it's the look after -
cuz if they just put the weird twang on
it like I'll go up board for war but
it's the look like did I do it that's
not like no you didn't know I'll take it
if you do right cuz they take it as do
you understand me and that's why they
get upset it's condescending he's a
sweet guy he really was literally just
trying to learn Spanish yeah and this
guy was too got so offended and I was
just like okay tone it down but it
sounds like he's mocking them yes that's
why I do hands especially when you're
super white Oh hand gestures wrong that
really helps
Flo ma gringo piece of [ __ ] that's what
this thing going loud one time I did I
was like but I was a high burrito please
they brought me a quesadilla rolled up
unbelievable I coulda burrito that's
what I complain they wrap the five
taquitos together with some string be a
good invention a tortilla rubberband
Ziggy yeah yeah yeah your logic is out
of this world I swear to God woman one
more time well yeah so this story made
headlines because of the fact that
initially it was just like oh my god
there's this surveillance footage of the
sixteen-year-old girl being taken off
the street which was walking with her
mom that's so crazy I hope she's okay
and turns out that she just seems like
that is crazy she's locked up now
imagine if it was a white girl I really
would have went national so you asked if
she's getting locked up so they're
saying that something she's not expected
to face charges but they are the cops
are still looking into questioning the
men who were with her in the car
oh yeah yeah I mean whose idea was it
anyway I wonder if she really
masterminded this or her boyfriend or
well whose idea was because if there was
her idea there's somebody irresponsible
on the other hand yeah because if she's
16 and her 23 year old boy exactly it's
like let's do that
those are his homeboys yeah that's his
crew all right you guys set this up he
probably didn't say anything you bro -
yes go for a ride you know you say we'll
be doing all right here's what we'll do
there's my girl let's pretend like we
kidnapping her you know what just what
does the breeze open carrying or like
what if there's a cop there sometimes
they're crazy well luckily no one got
hurt nope someone got hurt the mom got
hurt
Dhar yeah she's gonna bring that up all
the time yeah every time I see stuff
like that I'm like we all need to have
guns a lot of it yep they're shooting at
the car that would help yep
just launched shoot at the car so me
yeah what a tragedy this would have been
this is what a bit of more interesting
story I think yep
Oh what mob kills three men mom whose
daughter from kidnapping she didn't need
to be rescued
a bystander is black because they
wouldn't middle you think mom had a good
name would have been like you know 13
people killed in tragic mistake he had a
dot yeah dot daughters head blown off
because Mom you know and the dog play
stupid games wind stupid prizes that's
called memory situations that's what I
say you know birthday parties a really
good I don't know that just seems
weddings I like those weddings where you
in the in the reception or was like
rushing ever see Pablo Escobar's wedding
video yeah he did that beautiful Russian
weddings a jet to yeah crazy yeah play
Russian roulette
but with a real bullet in it marry or
die what did you do that during the vows
like every value so you have to do it
like you know I promise to love honor
quick like some real love right there
amazing something how are you guys react
if you saw this [ __ ] happening not my
kid your kid oh you're a bystander do
you think you would jump in Bart would
punch through the window and pull the
guy out I have a terrible terrible story
okay it just makes me look terrible but
I'm gonna tell it anyway I was in I was
in New York it was kind of late walking
down the street there's a couple walking
ahead of me and so as I'm walking a lot
you see their back of the flash see
their back as I'm walking some guy kind
of like bumps past me you know what I
mean yeah and then he starts just he was
crazy you just starts attacking this
couple whoa homeless man he hits you and
then attacks a couple
he pumps me right and it goes over Ewing
spits on the girl
and then he like start swinging and then
the guy and the guy you know what I did
I walked across the street no part of
this
yeah home is when I look back on it I go
oh my god what a cowardly move I know I
should have jumped in and helped you
know he's he's [ __ ] up in the head
like when they're homeless or on drugs
I don't even yeah but I started peeing
on that guy he wouldn't stop doing yeah
I know but it was like cross stream and
call someone for help
no because the guy was already it was it
was in New York it was like so we ran
this guy the guy to his credit he did
not let it go like I'm talking about cuz
I was still walking and everybody you
know this guy was like and he did it for
like 20 minutes until the cops finally
came a girl because they kept no no they
kept they kept going
this is so outgoing I'm like these
people are still this still going on
yeah the whole situation was following
me and I was like ugh I should have done
something is that spitting on it this is
how that makes it this guy's spitting on
the chick he's like wailing on the gun
on them and this guy's just lecture him
he's like we're gonna get you on Rico
we're gonna get Chara the gun but it was
after like it was like clearly the guy
was now just kind of walking away you
know but he just went crazy for a second
you know you just wanted to do that you
know lady got handled he was like yeah
and I was like I saw it I was like nope
you know and I look back and I was like
what am i doing I should have you know
what would you have done though just pop
your wings and go go over push the guy
away you know like you know but you
don't know the guy could out of knives
they got exactly so what I mean but my
instinct wasn't to be like a hero my
instinct was to be myself but you know
what the problem too is at the time I
was boxing a lot too oh you're an even
bigger [ __ ] I know I was like by you
well I would've came and been hold your
hands up and call out my punches
[Laughter]
so it was like but this stupid part I
mean I just think you don't know what
you're gonna do in certain situations
but I was just like ooh I don't want no
part of this
I'm always sizing it up it's okay to be
a Kurd I'm like no it's not you got to
pick and choose your battles
and you did the right thing I chose he
could bite you yeah I don't know about
crazy I know I can have hepatitis right
is that here although no maybe maybe
marbles gonna put him in a movie okay
yeah but here's the thing just maybe but
even worst part about it is he could
have been this - it could have been
somebody could a film they've been like
look at Montez from working hard but if
you were Dwayne the rock and we're gonna
be like Dwayne the rock is a [ __ ] yeah
cuz you're Montez from workaholics yeah
works for you this that's the power of
branding
[Music]